yo it's your buddy josh can't wait for
you to check out this clip
it's from a special that i shot over
quarantined in front of a
socially distanced masked 20-person
crowd so if you can't hear the crowd
imagine how i felt love this material
can't wait for you to check it out watch
the whole special
father time later everybody you can't
blame the kids
and i'm gonna tell you why you can't
blame them they've had porn in their
pockets since they were 13
12. none of that shocks them but they
have been exposed to so much more like
they had poor if i wanted porn i had to
go into the woods
find the magazines that one of the older
dudes in the neighborhood hid
and take a look and then put them
underneath back underneath the piece of
wood you know i mean that's how we did
it
i would say that our generation had more
of a porn problem than this guy because
it's been in his pocket the whole time
we had to go into the woods so like
we're hungry for it
and you listen you can't bring a hungry
guy doing all you can eat buffet we're
going to stuff ourselves you know what
i'm saying so
the minute i found out and realized that
they were
exposed to so much more than us was the
time my son told me he got invited to a
rainbow party my wife and i were both
like
what is a rainbow party and it was
disturbing
high school party ten guys five girls
all the girls were a different color
lipstick this is true and
and the winner is the girl who gets her
color on the most dudes
that's a high school party yeah and he
was like hey
i don't i don't think i'm going
and i said why not i don't understand
it seems like a good party for you to go
to dude you know and he was like dad
i've never i've never
i've never had one of those before and
like
you know people are going to be watching
what if i don't perform under that kind
of pressure you know what i mean
and he said and plus my first time i
thought it'd be special like a special
night
and i was like you know what dude i'm
sorry i poked fun of you and
and let's sit down and talk about this
like adults you know
and i just sat him down and i said
listen you wanted the truth and he said
yeah i said okay here's the truth
the truth is the truth about that party
the truth is is that you
have got to go to that [ __ ] party are
you kidding me right now
you're guaranteed one [ __ ] that is a
special night dumbass i don't know
the only thing we should be talking
about is if you need a ride you need to
ride to that party because i'll drive
you over there
sherry you have kids they're on their
way to that party right now are you
kidding me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]